My name is Mihir.
I'm 15 years old, and I'm a sophomore at Fox Chapel Area High School in Pittsburgh.
I started visiting the Carnegie Science Center from an early age.
It's full of fun and interactive exhibits,...
...which helped spark my interest in science and develop a love for robotics.
Last summer, my family and I went to India on vacation.
We returned to find our house filled with fruit flies,...
...as we had left some bananas on the kitchen counter.
After many failed attempts trying to swat them,...
...I started to realize how amazing the fruit fly's escape is.
I had been reading about flying robots at the time, and one thing that struck me...
...was the similarities in the environments in which both fruit flies...
...and flying robots have to operate.
I wanted to see whether we could draw from biology...
...to make flying robots truly autonomous,...
...so they could potentially be used in robot-assisted rescue missions...
...in environments like collapsed buildings.
I wanted to apply my learnings from fruit fly escape behaviors...
...to a multirotor helicopter.
I used a sheet of plywood to simulate an approaching threat...
...while testing different algorithms.
And I was really excited when my robot managed to escape...
...with a success rate of a hundred percent across 20 attempts.
I'm really optimistic about the world of tomorrow.
I want to save lives with flying robots...
...and use computer science and robotics to make a difference.
This is a world that I'd like to be a part of,...
...but more importantly, one that I'd like to help create.